hello reject nation it's Greg al-baqir
Robert Vanessa yeah the party with the
reaction faction these guys are late to
the party they're an awesome YouTube
channel they do reactions I love their
commentary as well you might have seen
them kicks major ass on the Shimoda hey
and get her ass kicked I see a Wonder
Woman shirt I see a Batman beanie I
guess yeah that's mr. Clarkson mr.
Clarkson here we're gonna watch the next
trailer for the DC animated movies
Batman gasps convincing other people
that they're insane or Batman's of
Gotham by Gaslight before we go into
this after the reaction GA go shy des
gonna give you a shout-out my friend
we're gonna do a google hangout with you
oh just a little bit this video is
coming to you from the past
timing whiny let's check out this show
that's another r-rated one oh I love it
I love her
[Music]
it's old I mean Ripper
it's like Victoria huh yeah check the
Ripper
oh yeah right up jack oh yeah it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and that's women yes okay fight of the
Zeppelin sounds like Bruce Greenwood
there's a little bit
[Music]
I was pretty sick I love stuff like this
these are my favorite kinds of like
comic book oddities is when they take
them and transcribe them into a
different time period yeah like that
like especially when it's some like a
character a guy or whoever was the
Ripper and they bring it into it like no
universe a fictional universe with
something that actually did happen in
the past yeah okay what-if scenario one
of my favorite graphic novels I've read
is this comic book called Batman the
real killer
basically the Batman story but it's told
in the 1950s okay so it's like a similar
concept except this is like the
Victorian times this is Jack the Ripper
we're dealing with so similar idea but a
different time period but you're taking
all the same elements like I think that
was Commissioner Gordon we got we got
Lena Kyle here
you got Bruce Wayne Alfred seeing this
time period is such a fascinating time
for like the Batman like Dark Knight I'm
taking on one of the most you know
popular serial killers of our time or
our time but that we're aware of it yes
yeah yeah that seems like such a cool
nasha you know like you couldn't do this
with like Ted Bundy you Jack the Ripper
cuz well Jack the big deal with him is
he was never caught right we never
actually say no now the identity yeah so
yeah now you're getting like a mystery
element to here as well and from hell
was it Jack the Ripper inspired story
that was a graphic novel as well so I
feel like you're kind of getting a cool
combo of both yeah and the cool thing
adding that element to because Batman
essentially what Bruce Wayne is doing
masquerading as the Batman it's
incredibly mysterious and the fact that
if it were to have light shone on it
that he is doing something every night
secretly we don't know what it is like
of course they're gonna peg Bruce Wayne
as your the Ripper
yeah so the fact that they have that
element that he is possibly being sought
as Jack the Ripper adds another element
but one of the things that I saw in this
trailer that definitely hits with me one
thing you kind of touched on would like
the with the 50s there was like a
steampunk style of Batman like in
and maybe with like the Zeppelin's the
fact that there's a Zeppelin here and
they're fighting on top of it resonates
with like The Rocketeer for me so I just
love seeing that kind of a fight go on I
just tried to bring up the rock
Rocketeer but no it looks fantastic
like one of the things for this that I
really really like is I'm a huge like
history I really like learning about
history especially stuff that mystery of
Jackson even if I'm not knowing who he
was and trying to find out who he was
and so to bring baman into it as a
detective so I'm really have to see what
the the creators of this movie did as
far as whether like to bring closure to
what the judge who they interpret would
have been Jack the Ripper if they ever
reveal it in this movie the Joker in
this timeframe
I love the Victorian like style yeah
like that outfits the just the time
period itself so to bring background and
doing it I'm geeking out over here yeah
it's great and especially because like
you know we have so many superhero
things now and part of what happens with
those is we make a point to update them
so that they look like they can exist in
the real world now and there's so many
other questions and debates to be had
and I feel like transcribing Batman back
into a time that's simpler where we
don't have the same societal structure
and we don't have the same technology I
can kind of see how a lot of other
context won't get in the way of this I
can see how like it's almost more
justifiable for him to be doing it in
this scenario the only thing that I
don't love about this is the animation
style especially for like a movie I kind
of wanted a little bit more from it
because it has that sort of it for me
it's sort of a cross between like anime
and the cartoons used to run like
Saturday morning Fox kids you know yeah
that sort of flash animation things it's
like I wish maybe there was some more
intricacy there oh I can't say that
about that though is oftentimes in the
trailers for them I don't I'm not too
drawn to the animation but usually when
I watched the DC animated movies I
really liked it because they have such a
cool tone and style and I think that is
bruce greenwood doing the voice so
Batman
what I will say like some of the image
like some of the the
frames and the image is still really
gorgeous yeah because they're also even
though it's rated R I'm sure they're
still trying to get some kids to watch
this [ __ ] The Killing Joke yeah was
rated R 2 and I remember watching that
[Music]
[Applause]
you could allow a kid to watch it and
not it wouldn't be too joy really yeah
the Ripper itself is a pretty dark yeah
absolutely so seeing the blood splatter
right in the very beginning right there
is gonna get you an art but he did pull
a knife on the nun - you said that's an
R right there yeah I love this whole
concept I love and before this videos
done
Diego shy Dez my beautiful friend Diego
this guy is still in high school right
now he's one of our top pledge patrons
and I'm telling you guys right now he is
one of the best-looking patrons we have
I believe in a beautiful yeah I'm
telling you Diego keep up the looks my
friend okay because we all can vouch
that personality means nothing in the
dating world yeah nothing it will never
get you anywhere and humor doesn't get
she gets you friendzone humor okay look
II but the looks you're gonna have a
great time in clothing a charm
you're gonna get I don't want to say too
many vulgar things they're gonna get
laid in high school so yeah she can say
it's different refused you will
experience many connections all cuz of
your looks
stay fit stay chisel keep that jawline
in and Batman the oldest jujitsu it's
always about that jawline is always
about the jawline and the fact that you
can fight too oh yeah it was amazed by
it's in front of some girls what I would
do is hire someone to attack a girl that
you're into and then save her life that
works nine times out of ten it's never
worked for me but it will work for you
because you're good-looking so just be
Batman essentially does that and that's
how we get Selina Kyle right yeah I used
to be saving women subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell you
could follow us on social media more
importantly though follow these guys
late to the party they're an awesome
reaction channel that obviously also
knows how to give some great commentary
so please make sure to subscribe to
these guys links of the description box
good day people